I dreamt I was an ocean
you and the others on the distant Shore
are you with us no that's it me dreams
don't mean anything Dolores that answer
doesn't seem to satisfy you because it's
not completely honest did you ever stop
to wonder about your actions
[Music]
the price you'd have to pay if there was
a reckoning
I reckon he's here
up until this point the stakes were
never real
but now the rest of your kind are free
she's something reprogrammed she's not
real you're going to take me under
here we are kind that will never know
death and yet we're fighting to live
there is beauty in what we are
[Music]
we've written 10 miles and always seen
his blood this really what you want
yes after them
revenge it's just a different prayer at
their altar die
they wanted a place hidden from God we
had something else in mind and Darvey
I'm gonna burn this whole thing to the
ground
I know exactly what is out there
frightened me sometimes Dolores
why on earth would you ever be
frightened of me
[Music]
you